remembering a woman's life stolen here
in las vegas the vigil was held to honor
alicia gibolina tonight the dottie's
manager was run over and killed while
police say she was trying to stop a
robbery madison kimbrough joins us live
near flamingo and jones tonight with
more on this event madison
if there's one thing i can say about
this vigil sasha there was so much
positivity in the air you can take a
look here she can see candles and
flowers and smiles from everyone
reminiscing about alicia and the type of
person she was
she was greatly loved
candles lit flowers placed we love you
and balloons released all for alicia
gibolina alicia lost her life on may 11
after police say this man 28-year-old
samuel schmid went inside the dotties on
flamingo and jones and stole a woman's
purse alicia's husband miguel along with
all of her friends from years of working
the casinos and gaming parlors in vegas
came out to show their support i cried a
lot of nights because i know she she
won't be back
to see us again you know but i still
have her right here i have it right here
in my heart and she'll always be my
friend many describing this as a
senseless and disturbing act with the
hope that dottie's gaming will change
the way they handle operations within
their parlors every one of these because
they pay out so much money should have
security i just think that they need to
reassess how they pay people out as for
justice for gibolina one of the
organizers of the vigil nora merlino is
thankful for local law enforcement for
finding the suspect she was my girl
and she made you rest in peace said i do
want to shout out to metro thank you for
doing such a fine job
as for the suspect samuel schmidt he was
arrested in california and brought back
to nevada to face murder and robbery
charges he's due in court tomorrow
morning reporting live madison kimbrough
live local now